-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Nick Kroll.
We discussed your parents.
How, especially --
You talk about childbirth
in this special.
How does your wife respond
to the idea of putting
her stories in your act?
-Well, I think, my wife, Lily,
has been really helpful
throughout the process of coming
up with working on this hour.
And she was like,
"If you're gonna talk about,
like, the birth of our child,
don't do some
bull [bleep]
little joke about it," you know?
And so, it forced me to kind of
actually get into what matters.
And it helped me eventually
get to the point where,
I make fun of moms, but then
in talking about childbirth,
it's like you understand
why moms are so --
we're so tied to our moms and
that complicated relationship.
And I definitely would not
have gotten there without,
like, really talking through
all that with my wife, Lily.
So I'm very grateful to her.
-It's very special to have
someone who can
collaborate that way on
the writing of material
about important things.
-Yes.
I mean, she writes all my jokes.
I am a vessel for them.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, absolutely.
And then my --
Alexi writes all my jokes
and is very hard on me
when I get it wrong.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She's backstage, like -- yeah.
-"Stick to what was
on the page."
-Yeah, like a dance mom.
She's like, "You failed!"
[ Laughter ]
You took --
you did something very risky.
-Mm-hmm.
-You had a movie premiere
at the Venice Film Festival.
-Yes.
-And you went on a red-eye
with a 1 1/2-year-old.
-Yes, me and my wife,
and we flew with our son.
You know, when you fly,
your worst nightmare is,
you fly with your child and that
your child is gonna be loud
and unpleasant on a plane.
-Yeah.
-And we thought
we had timed it well.
Like, we got --
It was a 7:00 flight.
We get on there with him.
You know, we've got all his --
We put him in his
little sleep sack, you know.
For those of you
who don't have kids,
sleep sacks are like
a sleeping bag with a tank top.
And I'm like,
"Oh, I want to wear that.
Why don't they make
an adult-sized that?"
And then, you know,
we get him ready for bed.
We start reading him some books.
We read him all of
the light-night show hosts.
We read him Kimmel's book,
we read him Fallon's book,
uh, Corden's book...
[ Laughter ]
...and, um...
-And --
Greg Gutfeld's book.
-Oh, my God.
And, um...
[ Laughter ]
"Here's What the Libs Don't
Want You to Know About Sleep."
-It is very good.
I don't agree with him
all the time,
but it's very good.
-It's very good.
-And then he goes --
And then he misses his window,
and he's then awake.
And he starts screaming.
And for the --
almost the entire red-eye,
he will not fall asleep.
And, like, we have people
trying to give him advice.
This woman, who I think was
at one point a model, came up.
[ Laughter ]
And she was, like,
"Maybe I should hold your baby."
And she picked him up.
And my son, like --
You know, 'cause she looked like
a bunch of paper airplanes
covered in marzipan.
[ Laughter ]
And my son freaked out.
And so then
he's crying the entire --
literally the entire flight.
We land in Venice,
and this guy gets off the plane,
and he's wearing a seersucker
suit and a Panama hat.
I think it's like a mob boss.
Like a proper
Italian Mafia boss.
He is not happy about it.
I then get to baggage claim.
I realize,
it's not a Mafia boss.
It's Brendan Fraser.
[ Laughter ]
And he's so pissed.
And then we go out that night,
and I see Natasha Lyonne
is at the festival.
-Yep.
-And she was like,
[ Coarse voice ]
"How was your flight?"
And I was like,
"It was all right.
My kid cried a bunch."
She's like, "That was your kid
on the plane?"
[ Laughter ]
She was like,
"That was like Lou Reed."
And -- I don't know.
Whatever.
Anyway, so, find out that
Brendan Fraser was talking about
how much my son
was crying on the plane
that he wouldn't fall asleep,
he couldn't get
a good night's sleep.
I was like, I felt terrible.
It's your worst nightmare
that you're gonna be the people
whose kid is screaming
on the red-eye.
The next night,
I go to a premiere with my wife,
and we go to see this movie
called "The Whale."
-Starring Brendan Fraser.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
And he plays
this, like, 600-pound man.
And the movie,
he's amazing in the film.
And he's one of my favorite
actors, from "Encino Man"
to where he's a Jew
in "School Ties."
-Yeah.
-So believable.
[ Laughter ]
To the documentary "The Mummy."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The follow-up documentary,
"The Mummy Returns."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And then, finally,
he's in this movie.
This is his big comeback.
The movie finishes.
He gets an eight-minute
standing ovation.
People are -- he's crying.
You can feel him being like,
"I'm back, baby.
It's the Oscars.
Here we come."
He then turns around,
and me and my wife are standing
directly behind him.
And he looks at us,
and then I pull up my baby.
[ Laughter ]
And he starts crying.
And my wife
took a picture of him
just at the moment
he looked at us.
And if you can look closely,
you can see Brendan Fraser...
[ Laughter ]
...realizing that
we have ruined his night.
[ Laughter ]
-"The one person I said
don't give a ticket to
was Kroll's baby."
-I know!
What are you gonna do?
I mean...
-Congratulations on the special.
It's fantastic.
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
Nick Kroll!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Little Big Boy"
is streaming on Netflix.
And "Don't Worry Darling"
is in theater's now.
We'll be right back
with Steve-O.